and you are looking at a live picture  right now of president trump he is in  the  rose garden of the white house where in  washington right now it is well  well past nine o'clock in the evening so  this is a fairly unusual precedent  but he has just now begun the  swearing-in ceremony for our  new supreme court justice amy county  barrett  who was confirmed just a little bit more  than two  hours ago so working very quickly here  as you can see flanked to his left is  judge clarence thomas  getting ready for that swearing-in  ceremony of the youngest and newest  member of our supreme court  we will keep an eye on this event for  you throughout the evening and have more  in later newscasts